[Música]
bueno voy a empezar con una obviedad
que es que el mundo está cambiando de
toda leche
cuando me salió la vena de consultor
preparando ayer decir bueno voy a traer
unas gráficas como las empresas
sube cambias en 50 años las empresas
líderes necesitan 50 años tras salir del
total y luego la de javier como por
supuesto cuando me di cuenta que
ensayando que ya iba por el minuto 25
dije que hay que cortar y además está
recortar para que para algo que está
clarísimo el mundo están cambiando a
toda leche
y a mí lo que realmente me interesa no
es que esté cambiando toda leche sino el
impacto que esto va a tener en nuestras
carreras profesionales en el mundo
laboral y en nuestros empleos y el
impacto
va a ser descomunal ya lo está haciendo
porque va a ser descomunal yo aquí
afirmo
y seguro que si me equivoco me
equivocaré poco que en un horizonte de
cinco o diez años ninguna profesión
ninguna profesión y habrá unas pocas
excepciones
no va a sufrir un cambio brutal que nos
obliga a todos
a los que son de esa profesión
adaptarse o directamente son profesiones
que van a desaparecer
algunos ejemplos
empleados de call center
con tablets auxiliares administrativos
hay una tecnología que si no está madura
ya está
en un momento muy cercano a la madurez
que es la automatización el puesto de
trabajo esos puestos de trabajo peligran
puesto oficios también muy glamourosos
en el de toda la época
hay consenso también entre todos los
analistas que son oficios envía esa
aparición y habló por ejemplo de los
pilotos
los médicos estos no van a desaparecer
pero sí que también existe un cierto
consenso diciendo que hay un cambio
brutal en las tareas en el mix de lo que
hacen las máquinas lo que hace el médico
el 80% de las tareas que hacen los
médicos diagnósticos rutinarios etcétera
etcétera
parece que claro que lo van a asumir las
máquinas con lo cual los médicos hay que
evolucionar y yo creo que son una buena
noticia al cosas de mayor valor añadido
y que requiera un contacto humano más
estrecho
pero es que lo que nos viene ahora
es aún más
el coche autónomo esto que está aquí hay
gente domingo alonso que de seguro se va
gente más de ellos que yo de esto pero
hay unas pruebas súper maduras en alguna
ciudad de estados unidos esto está la
vuelta a la esquina imagínese el impacto
que va a tener esto en los en los
empleos ligados a la conducción en los
taxistas los conductores de vtc los
camioneros
y aquí descuento la robótica
de aquí pero más impacto que va a tener
la robótica en todas las profesiones que
son más físicas en todo lo que tiene que
más artístico más de contenidos la
realidad virtual la realidad aumentada
es que incluso las las profesiones más
seguras y aquí aprovecho para hacer
un pequeño inciso cuando me preguntan
oye que tendría que estudiar mi hijo y
yo solo digo informática
cuántos empleos ahora mismos en qué
profesiones puedes decir con la que nos
está cayendo que seguro van a tener
trabajo
esa y unas cuantas más yo estoy
intentando comer loco con mi hija tiene
10 años la pobre pero para que le guste
la informática porque es quedará que se
me ocurren muy pocos oficios que estén a
prueba de disrupción total
pues bueno incluso ellos los
informáticos qué suerte ellos pues
aproximadamente cada 34 años vino una
tecnología que lo arrasa todo hace que
la anterior sea obsoleta y tienen que un
aprender de nuevo estoy exagerando un
poco pero no está maceta larrea y si lo
peor es que todo se acelera aún más y al
final vamos al punto que quiero hacer
que es que
la incertidumbre laboral ya reina pero
es que va a reinar el triple el cuadro
pero mucho más a medida que pasa el
tiempo cada vez esto va a ser más
incierto
en medio de toda esa incertidumbre pues
hay una no ha sido una capacidad clave
en una competencia clave
que creo que es el
no es el único pero claramente un
antídoto una vacuna contra esta
incertidumbre brutal que nos acosa si
quieren ponerlo en positivo pues es una
enorme oportunidad
aquel que con que aquel o aquella que
controle que domine está esta capacidad
vamos a poder triunfar va a poder sacar
partido antes hablaban de las crisis las
dos maneras de salir de la crisis pues
es salir en positivo de esta
incertidumbre laboral que es un hecho
y llegó al título que creo que es la
tercera vez curiosamente en las
ponencias que lo que los que lo
mencionan
desaprender para poder aprender
esa es la competencia clara de aprender
rápido saber adaptarse saber en poco
tiempo poder
reinventarse y
absorber conocimiento y capacidades yo
no soy ni pedagogo
ni científico ni tampoco es
particularmente dicho en ciencias
cognitivas y nada eso yo no voy por ahí
yo quiero simplemente
atacar este tema desde el punto de vista
de las carreras de las carreras
profesionales desde el punto de vista
laboral y para eso sí que me siento
medianamente
legitimado supongo que la organización
también pensado lo mismo si no no sé muy
bien lo que oye y por qué por qué
ya son casi 30 años de carrera
profesional
con todo en dos denominadores común
1 la tecnología y otra la consultoría
estratégica
y son ambos dos creó sitios donde esto
de aprender ir a toda leche y
exigir que un aprendizaje continuo y muy
rápido esos son de unos menores comunes
y para eso lo mejor casi esa industria
luego una anécdota real que me pasó a mí
yo estaba en la época de manager que
bueno para el mundo la consultoría es
cuando ya empiezas a gestionar equipos
de 34 personas
a una responsabilidad fuerte porque eres
la persona digamos más señor que está
full time en el equipo lo voy a por
encima tienes los socios y tal y bueno
yo acaba de terminar mi proyecto estaba
en madrid tan tranquilo pues disfrutando
de y esperando que me asignará un nuevo
proyecto
y me llamó un socio llama a su despacho
y todas estas conversaciones siempre en
el igual no es hijo javier t en un
proyecto para ti maravilloso que te
encaja en tu carrera
todas son iguales les ahorro todo esto
pero estar un miércoles más o menos y me
dijo a ver el proyecto
te vas a ir arabia saudí riad el lunes
que viene
porque vamos a hacer un proyecto de
transformación del sector público
yo nunca había hecho un proyecto de
sector público
imagínense arabia saudi
no se me ocurren pocos países cuyo
sector público sea más diferente a los
que conocemos en europa occidental con
lo cual ni siquiera podía tirar el
sentido común y lo tenía en un miércoles
y apaga el lunes tiene que ir a una
reunión de kickoff con el cliente y que
el cliente tiene que dar medianamente
tranquilo de que tenía un equipo capaz
que iba a controlar y que iba a añadir
valor
yo creo que pánico es una palabra que
define
un poquito lo que yo sentir aquellos
momentos vale ok he elegido
probablemente el extremo más el ejemplo
más extremo de mi carrera ok lo
reconozco pero cualquiera que he vivido
esto esto era bastante normal vale no
tan extremo como esto ok pero esto de
sector es nuevo
países nuevos problemas nuevos hasta el
0,1 adaptarse boom para reuniones estará
el día a día en la consultoría
estratégica y bueno mágicamente esto
funcionaba estas son empresas que
todavía vienen facturan muy reputadas
con lo cual visiblemente esto funciona
también es verdad que estamos muy
apoyados pero
tienes una red mundial que te ayuda con
gente que ha tenido problemas similares
y que te ayuda a resolverlos un
departamento reset espectáculo así pero
al final del día la presión recae sobre
las espaldas del consultor o la
consultora que tenía que poner las pilas
en cero coma
y porque les cuento todo este rollo
porque quiero que me crean cuando les
digo para mí lo que es uno de los
mensajes más importantes
de la
de esta ponencia que es que esto de
aprender a aprender
es un músculo
podemos entrenarlo
por supuesto que el talento tiene mucho
que ver obviamente hay gente que aprende
a mayor velocidad hay gente que tiene
dotes dotes innatas para aprender y para
absorber conocimiento por supuesto pero
en qué parte en qué ámbito de la vida
eso no es verdad
yo
en la vida voy a poder correr una
maratón en tres horas o si alguien tiene
alguna duda
en la vida
vale y eso el dólar ismo no tengo ese
talento ni lo tenía cuando era un
poquito más delgado
pero sí que sé otra cosa que quiere
hacerlo pero sí que sé que si me pongo
me pongo y entreno todos los días
chimpún sin pan pues bajaré de mis
patéticas no sé ni siquiera en cuánto
tiempo porque una maratón pero vamos a
decir seis horas pues ser capaz de bajar
quizás a cuatro entonces
pues en esto es igual esto lo visto no
solo en consultores lo visto en clientes
lo visto en todos lados es un músculo
que se puede entrenar y es fundamental
que lo entrenamos por lo que he dicho
antes
en la la es el arma
definitiva que nos puede ayudar contra
la incertidumbre la carabantes y tenemos
y debemos todos de manera consciente
entrenar este músculo
vale
y ahora la pregunta del millón no y esto
cómo se hace
y aquí sí que voy a defraudarles porque
como he dicho ni soy científico
cognitivo ni nada de esto yo voy a
limitar muy humildemente a dar cuatro
consejos que he visto cuando he visto a
los mejores haciendo esto
son denominadores comunes y que a mí
también particularmente me han ayudado
mucho en toda mi carrera
el primero
es creérselo
la gente que mejorase esto de aprender y
absorber tiene unos juegos así y está
bien tiene una confianza en sí mismo
brutales yo aquí sí que me lo preparé un
pelín viendo webs de
pedagogía y de
y de temas cognitivos y tal y allí no
sean los consejos había unanimidad entre
profesores y tal diciendo que la
confianza en sí mismo creo que con una
maravillosa ponencia que puso de la
chica americana
decían que importante era que los
alumnos tuvieran confianza en sí mismo
pues bueno te voy a dar una pista
maravillosa pues pues si hay que
creérselo es fundamental y algunos
pensarán vale majete javi
cojonudo tienes que creer en ti mismo
para aprender a qué gran mensaje vale
pues me vuelvo a remitir al ejemplo de
la maratón
si yo todos los días me pongo un reto un
poquito más difícil no se impulse
acciones en correr en distancia
recorrida etcétera etcétera estoy
convencido de que era un momento no ya
que vea que vaya progresando se traslade
y el ecunhi por el amor soy capaz de
correr una maratón
pues esto es igual si nos ponemos retos
alcanzables cada vez mayores etcétera
etcétera pues lo mejor vamos creando
la confianza en nosotros mismos que
vivimos para esto
el siguiente elemento
es la rigidez mental
también creo que lo han dicho antes está
genial ser uno de los últimos porque
estás reforzando ideas que han dicho
antes él por desgracia todos cuando
tenemos una cierta edad
nos empezamos a instalar en el no es
posible no me lo creo esto no es todo
esto no va etc
y estos terribles
tampoco los voy a decir nada del otro
mundo con el gigante para aprender hace
falta curiosidad e ilusión
y esto también tiene
consecuencias importantes en las
decisiones que tomamos
imagínense instalarse en el no quiero no
es posible no me lo creo etcétera
creo que espero ver la convención la
primera parte de la potente de la
ponencia que esto es una actitud suicida
en el entorno laboral que nos movemos
pues hay que conseguir eliminar esa
rigidez y no me lo creo no es posible es
ser hay que conseguir hacerlo
y me remito a muchísimos ejemplos que
seguro que todos conocemos de abuelitas
o de padres y madres de una cierta edad
que se ponen con el móvil y el pc que
les parece un mundo y que aprenden y tal
tenemos que tener esa actitud y no es
tan difícil cambiarla simplemente es
cuando te sé cuando cuando eres
consciente todos los seres humanos
tenemos resistencia al cambio en mayor o
menor medida
sí si eres consciente de eso esto como
cuando eres alcohólico no lo primero
para curarte es el consciente que lo
eres pues y somos conscientes que
tenemos ese demonio interior que nos
dice nada hasta nos posible no me lo
creo pues si somos conscientes de eso
pues lo mejor podemos combatirlo
el cuarto consejo que me permito darles
es
un poquito más técnico es este binomio o
esta dicotomía entre la amplitud y la
profundidad si queremos ver el
conocimiento o aquello que queremos
aprender como una matriz no o mejor un
ejemplo si nos queremos
aprender un tocho de mil páginas y no
tenemos tiempo ni energía para hacerlo
la amplitud sería pues el índice ver
todos los todos los temas que contienen
por ejemplo si yo quiero saber si yo
quiero aprender de energías renovables
lo primero que quiero probablemente
entender cuántos tipos de energías
renovables hay antes de ponerme a saber
hasta el último kilovatio hora de la
eólica fotovoltaica vale pues la
amplitud y luego la profundidad es pues
de cada tema pues llegará a ser el nivel
de experto muy requerido pues una y si
soy bastante tajante primero amplitud y
luego profundidad siempre así primero
amplitud y luego profundidad porque
cuando tienes amplitud te das cuenta
primero de lo grande que es la tarea que
tienes delante puedes elegir aquellos
temas que son más relevantes acuérdense
que esta ponencia es cómo aprender
rápido si tuviéramos tiempo y energía
infinita pues nada te metes el tocho
2000 y de
experto en amplitud y en profundidad
muy poco realista si empiezas por la
amplitud y eliges selectivamente
aquellos temas en los que sean más
relevantes y los otros los lees rápido o
ni siquiera te los leyes pues es una
buena estrategia
y por último
saber manejar las fuentes una fuente
adecuada
para el momento adecuado y para el
objetivo adecuado
y bueno esto sí que obviamente depende
muchísimo de los sectores del tipo de
conocimiento de los horizontales
verticales etcétera pero más o menos
siempre hay 5
en cinco de cinco tipos de fuentes la
primera es la que te da la amplitud
y hoy tenemos una cosa maravillosa se
llama internet
casi siempre suele bastar cuando tú
quieres tener el índice de aquel
conocimiento que quieres absorber o
abarcar casi siempre encuentras internet
algo que te da esa amplitud
profundidad no internet es muy peligrosa
para profundidad es muy difícil
discernir
el grano de la paja en internet pero
para amplitud suele bastar con un
segundo tipo de fuente que también
depende muchísimo del sector
es lo que llaman las news feed que te
permite mantenerte día a día y saber qué
está pasando no sé en mi época cuando se
suponía que era un experto en
telecomunicaciones pues había una cosa
que la biblia
que se llama total telecom que era una
cosa que te mandaba todas las mañanas un
mail con las noticias las cinco o seis
noticias lo que pasaba en el sector para
los 10 minutos el erte lo y te mantenía
al día la tercera fuente es la más
difícil que es la que te permite ganar
la profundidad son libros son
formaciones son incluso carreras
universitarias lo que tienen en común
estas es que son muy
golosas en tiempo
y requieren mucho tiempo y como con lo
cual hay que ser muy selectivo y elegir
en qué puntos de profundidad tenemos y
luego vienen las dos últimas que también
resuenan mucho con lo que han dicho a la
gente anteriormente que son las mejores
de todas que son las personas
la primera una entrevista con un experto
en consultoría lo sabíamos todos una
entrevista de una hora con un experto
del tema vale 40 horas de lectura o de
cursos de lo que sea porque te enfocas
te permites
decir el problema
adecuado para lo que te incumbe de
separar el grano de la paja etcétera
bueno
priceless como dice el anuncio y luego
el último
que ese es obviamente el más valioso de
todos pero que por supuesto no todos
tenemos la suerte de poder acceder es
trabajar con alguien que sepa
nada es mejor para aprender esos
conocimientos que trabajar codo con codo
con alguien que sepa muchas gracias